[Music]
to get started with a speech API for
nodejs you'll need a GCP project which
you can set up in the console
enable the speech API for that project
then create a service account and
download the private key as Jason you're
going to use these credentials to access
Google Cloud api's so keep this file
secure and out of your code and public
repos
to access the credential securely from
your project go to the terminal and set
an environment variable to the path of
your service account now prepare your
environment node.js development install
the client library if you use cloud
shell in the console you can skip this
step since the required dependencies are
already included for this example you'll
need some audio which contains speech to
transcribe there's a sample audio you
can download linked in the notes below
move your audio sample to the project in
a resources folder and change the name
of the file to make a generic for
example purposes now you don't actually
have to change the name of your file but
just remember to write it correctly when
prompted to write the file name to the
code make a new project file or open an
existing file open the google cloud
client library and the filesystem module
start with an async function called main
then instantiate a speech client provide
the file name of the audio file you want
to transcribe then use filesystem to
read the local audio file and convert it
to base64 encoding create a document
called audio with a field called content
set to that base64 string of the audio
provide some details about configuration
in an object called config you must
include the type of encoding the sample
rate in Hertz and the language of the
speech in the audio but there are also
optional fields you can find out more
about these fields in the API
documentation link below instantiate an
object called request which is made up
of the audio and config objects call
recognizer passing the request object
this returns a promise that resolves to
contain the result as zero or more
sequential speech recognition result
messages each speech recognition result
has a property called alternatives which
may contain one arm or rec
hypothesise an alternative has three
properties transcript confidence and
words transcript is a string
representing the words that the user
spoke confidence is a number between
zero point zero and one point zero where
a higher number indicates an estimated
greater likelihood that the recognized
words are correct words is an array of
word info objects I won't talk more
about word info since it goes beyond the
scope of this QuickStart
but if you're curious check out the API
reference to find out more to print out
the transcription get the first
alternative from each result then join
them in a single string log that
transcription run the main function and
include a catch block to handle any
errors save your file and run the code
if everything works properly you should
see the transcription of the text if not
take a look back at the code for any
syntax errors congratulations you've
just sent your first request to the
speech-to-text api to find out more
about the client libraries or consult
speech basics check out the cloud
documentation
[Music]